ladies and gentleman it's five week no
it's it's solar eclipse Monday to it you
know so glad you're on that I come so
glad you brought that I don't know if
you've seen that thing but to my wife
was like it's darker than normal and I
go it is she goes yeah and I go oh why
she was the Eclipse you the clips like
like the Mongols were coming like that's
the end of civilization I was American
Horse though the blood-red moon looks
super normal outside of me oh but if you
stay it if [ __ ] your eyes up did you I
look down went out I so I don't even
understand eclipses so apparently now
right now if I have glasses on I can see
the moon you can see it's all true
thrilled dark and it's covering the Sun
I don't give a [ __ ]
oh no let me tell you something I woke
up to Joanna's family at the house yeah
yeah of glasses on I'm like God I go out
there I'm like I look up like oh my god
my eyes were killing me
you know it's what stood out at all I
guess not all right man that looks like
a half crescent moon wait why is
everyone out here it's incredible I told
you had a friend type thing goes bro I'm
driving to Oregon Portland Oregon so I
can see the clips and follow it oh very
cool don't ever texted me again dude my
mother do you have anything else to do
do you have to take take a [ __ ] wash
your car I'm so dead Brendan you we're
gonna fly you to Portland Oregon and you
can collect coins I just Sonic the
Hedgehog all the way and follow that and
follow the solar eclipse I would not do
it
I'm little own full free my parents are
off somewhere and there with couple and
they're looking at the eclipse there's
apparently somewhere you see it really
well had a people my mother checks my
wife she goes I'm really bummed out my
whole family's in California and I'm
here looking at an eclipse yeah
oh you know our YouTube a stone a solar
eclipse and really see it the way you're
supposed to see well I remember when I
was in elementary school
maybe that's the last solar eclipse I
remember our teachers brought us outside
and I'm in third grade [ __ ] and she
goes no one stare at the Sun only third
grade of course all the stairs
don't say don't like it [ __ ] my eyes of
course and I did this morning had
flashbacks I'm telling you man
my eyes were jacked for about two
minutes did you jacked super Jeff oh
yeah
there's still not great that's not a
good thing well they say that heroin
addicts are sometimes when you be on
drugs people would go blind because I
like on acid I'll just do the stare at
the Sun they'll be like I can stare at
the Sun and they stare at the Sun so hot
they're blind blind and that's why I
never did acid now what's gonna happen
you could go blind and think the Sun is
your food
hi that's why I never did acid because I
heard a story about a guy who was took
way too many acid he took a bunch of
acid has and the next thing you know his
girlfriend put him in a bathtub and all
of a sudden he was in the bathtub and he
started to freak out and he's like oh no
chicken soup and he thought it was the
chicken soup and then these these that's
another level huh these shitty guys
weren't it was a house party that went
to the fridge and they started cutting
off its carrots and celery and
everything into it into the bathroom and
he was like look are you gonna make us
some chicken soup this girl was like
stop and you're freaking him out
apparently he was actually never the
same really
yeah because he thought he was a chicken
and [ __ ] they say they say ass can
change you for the worse when I was a
kid so uh my older friend the time
anthing Turner told me my brother yeah
this guy here about the guy started
peeling a skin like an orange god dammit
we're like wow yeah he took acid thought
he was a big old orange started peeling
skin like an orange whether or not that
I threw that's a horrible story work
though of course it happened me you
don't they only tell my kid that [ __ ]
kill I get that for everything like you
know if you keep playing with that phone
you're gonna turn the orange start
peeling the skin you want to hear my
mother's it word me when I was a kid
this is her story my mother said drugs
are very bad I said okay she goes well
we have a friend
everybody had a friend she didn't know
anybody this is this is an urban legend
of course and you've heard this I'm sure
cuz I've heard the orange peeling thing
it worked
it works she goes and she was
babysitting children they said how's the
baby the mother called and she said even
the turkeys doing just fine in the oven
and they came back and the baby was in
the oven and she had
the baby like a turkey because she was
on drugs and she thought the baby was a
turkey and I remember as a kid
first of all inappropriate story itself
way too appropriate I'm telling you
here's beanie I was probably I'm not
kidding eight I mean I can remember that
it's long far back as I can remember I
remember that story so she told me that
at a very young age hey you know too
much you not tell me about roasting a
child like a turkey that's too much yeah
there's some little stories they get
Hansel and Gretel what's hot song well
yeah that's exactly what she's a witch
she puts them in a cage she fattens him
up she's fattening him up because she's
gonna eat him that's that's the story of
Hansel and Gretel okay I'm fattening
these children up and I'm going to eat
you I live you know there's some stories
like that when you're kid you never
forget a man I know now like I'm peeling
horns I've never done acid I've been
around it people after me but since I
was a kid I was like I don't want pew my
skin like an orange yeah there's certain
things how about my how about this my
daughter's nine I'm driving her back
from my brother my brother-in-law's
place yesterday and she's it's 10:00 at
night and she's staying that way bad so
bad why she's having too much fun and
she's talking up a storm
she's just tossed out each other chatter
chatter but it's not it's not like her
yes she's asked me questions she's got
the coheres ask me no no bro she wasn't
doing lines man she's nine bro I don't
know no you're missing the point of the
story don't it rock with no siren don't
drug in robbing the derale Thunder rock
dragon or a nine-year-old the dune cook
so she's talking to me at a Hanuman I'm
like what's going on you're right
because I'm just talking to you I go oh
so what else daddy tell me a story tell
me story and I'm like what's going on
and you all right and just know I just
need to talk to you so you stay awake
and I go did auntie Kathleen tell you to
talk to me she goes yeah I said what'd
she say said he said if I don't talk to
you the whole way home you might fall
asleep and we could crash and die
hey Kathleen tell my daughter that the
poor thing is like she's exhausted but
she's up telling me stories she'll ask
me questions she's actually listening to
my advice which I was like this is weird
this is weird she never listens to me
there's certain thing man you don't
realize how big of an impact us
has long scary I remember when I was
super young my dad
we watched Robocop and there's scene
where he gets when he dies and then they
turn the road cop but I'm it's a
graphics handoff they're shooting him
like up like a jillion times yeah my dad
used to make us close our eyes and
sometimes he wouldn't he didn't know
it's coming we saw that I'm so
traumatized when he shot his hand off
they go give him a hand
crazy they pull his hand with a shotgun
he's it was horrifying
horrible I never forgot that I was
getting mad I was 6
Oh Mazel oh my god yeah my brother watch
sounds like oh my that's too much too
much it's way too much soon cuz Game of
Thrones my daughter was like what's this
swords and Dragon seems like I got
season 4 son I'm catching up dude I'm so
into it dude I'm sorry
I saw them nothing Jon Snow I saw the
eye shadow I would never slap no no I
would never but dude last episodes I've
seen that's what people are saying dude
the red would it the red wedding Oh deep
on this pescetarian diet eating my
salmon I'm watching like this a nice
little wedding that guy likes to I'm
like wonder why he's locked in the door
why is he wearing chain magnet breathe I
was like this whole time he got done I
was like oh my Lannister I always repay
that how come reason is it did I
remember my wife Khalifa so you guys
Khalifa what's up girl uh-huh what's up
girl oh you into dragons haha I'm gonna
drag these nuts across your face huh
that's not the kind of dragon wall time
she's in the dragon she's not in the
dragon she can't stand in the dragon
dragons Drago no don't drag nuts nuts
use dragon she's she's a pretty girl oh
yeah yeah she's a mother what the
whorehouse is back then they were
fantastic this is the problem though
everyone's getting pregnant all the time
everyone has bushes you know everyone
has bushes bush now so they listen they
don't they don't discriminate the [ __ ]
some dudes up in there too oh yeah I was
watching last night you know he's all
your [ __ ] to Prince like I sure haven't
you sure he's going to now Zeke oh damn
boy if you read Aristotle or Socrates
Plato like the great the great Greeks
they always in if you read the symposium
and stuff
always talk about [ __ ] boys like
they're like let's go ahead some wine
and there are really beautiful boys that
were that we can kiss what is that huh
it was just it was just in ancient
Greece I guess among the elite it was
perfectly fine to take a young boy they
would have them dyeing them in my
opinion it was just probably the Plato
and Socrates were gay and they happen to
be super smart but they were gay
throwing that in it's not exhausting man
let's go get some grapes hanging out
[ __ ] boys and it's fun to back up I was
down with the grapes and the sure well
the dirty secret is any culture that has
deep divisions between men and women
where boys are raised together and girls
are raised together and they're like
religious edicts around that yeah the
secret there is that boys get [ __ ] why
I heard like you know the Spartans we
know the 300 moving out badass and
tonight not all that [ __ ] well they
would raid those towns and [ __ ] [ __ ] the
man and boy sure would yeah that's the
real look at the real history well they
fry it's actually girls too but there
was always some if there's always that
moment of guys that were gay there's a
hardcore group of guys who were shredded
you are strip
oh sure they're some of those guys yeah
let's raid this town [ __ ] the guys with
beards ah mmm
my my I was down to raid the town my
buddy who worked with was intelligence
guy and knew a lot of the Special Forces
guys and there are young guys and and
they're Spartan call names you know and
they're just and they they spot each
other and they [ __ ] some even shave
their forearms they're like yes these
badass operators and stuff but they're
young studs they roll they practice this
and that all of them were like sitting
there when they don't ask don't tell
this is a long time ago
no this [ __ ] man gays in the
military some of them and my buddy was
like there's not a woman among any of
you [ __ ] guys you spot each other
with pull-ups holding it was going one
more set your roll
you got your shirts off all day long
you're all really good-looking guys if
you could you'd frost your [ __ ] hair
so shut up yeah do you how about I
didn't realize this I was watching this
thing today on this then you know
there's not one person who's gained out
any of them for major sports like crazy
mate Wow you know what it is you're in
the locker room and you're naked so I
would imagine that would be everybody's
not really here I mean officer I'm
pretty open mind and tempering gay but I
would not care man I really I wouldn't
do if I think when you're naked
I think things and you're in the shower
together because no way of collaborating
everybody covered though yeah you really
can like I know a guy who had a bush and
a small dick and out of my five years at
USC fella I never saw his dick wow he
just covered up and showered we'd see
the ass but it was whatever yeah he
wouldn't go in the sauna and the pole
tub like dresses but yeah I'm telling
you that's not an issue I don't know I
just like they they don't they don't I
think it's embarrassing for young men a
lot of young men who've been doing
sports their whole life don't have a
support system that's not a very good
support system right you come out in
you're like I'm gay everybody and all
you guys are I feel like I feel like you
get more support well probably but for a
guy moves out my damn other jokes in the
locker room are about girls and about
being gay right but it's all jokey jokes
but it's like it's the type of an VIN
VIN Nik Euler vernacular vernacular that
you know you just pass out like no one's
actually homophobe there are some but no
one's actually homophone you know I'm
saying like what it's just how you how
you cuz you're raised with dude don't be
gay like come on that looks gay I think
if we saw yeah if you actually good I
think of a gig if a guy came out and
said hey guys I'm gay alright like he
was just like I'm gay I like dudes what
are you gonna do alright get all the fun
make fun of me and stuff like that then
then you know I think if you gave the
guys the benefit of doubt most guys
would be like I don't give a [ __ ] how
could they four major sports and
everyone's like oh we're advanced
society and we're come a long ways and
I'm like god you're crazy feeling
thinking those four major sports and
it's out of four if you want to throw an
MMA box into that so five well you you
know you have some women who are out
loud and proud
but no no males that's very interesting
actually fast when they fit I went wow
that's actually fast as Michael Sam
remember he went on that whole campaign
and people like oh he's just getting
shunned because he's gay
he was in a good football player he's
good in college that's a big guy who had
his boyfriend yes he kissed him and
stuff yeah awesome twink his port was a
twink a little drafty my drink
I see that I was just caught me off
guard damn right I have a problem with
it but I was like oh damn gutsy dude to
do that I I appreciate it but he wasn't
good football player in the NFL he
wasn't good in college you SEC defense
plays a year from Missouri very good
football player in college just didn't
translate but a lot of people think he
came out saying I'm gay to get the
attention cuz he didn't have it I love
this look at that what's this
oh that's cake you silly Billy oh man
Jim dick in his mouth
ah what if this went over the top like
drafted number six I love that that's
nuts that he doesn't give AI nothing
yeah I think that's awesome just a
lifeguard get it boy I'd say that's his
girl right I mean his boy right hey
sorry
you know that because there's no way cuz
I'm gonna tell you that's a minute pal
my buddy John who's a an actor and he
came out and he likes thick athletic
black dudes and he had a guy that he
used to have you know having relations
running back I mean one running back
know in college big demon running back I
don't know his name but I bet he knew
hard yup and he goes and he goes I said
so you you were taking it he goes no I
was giving it to him I don't take it he
was I was giving the tail he said he
said I swear to God he goes he was a big
macho guy but he was banging him and I
was like and apparently apparently from
what I've read I've read this that it's
way more common for like they always say
that if a guy's a top and he walks into
a gay bar
it's he's he has his pick cuz um the
majority of the gay men in that bar are
probably gonna be bottoms and that tends
to be more common in the gay community
than is guys who bang dude that's what I
heard interesting that's true I feel
it's 50/50 I feel it would be 50 by
parents not alone apparently if you like
if you only bang guys near macho and you
don't get [ __ ] that's kind of a rarity
like and a lot of guys who are gay like
a masculine dude I remember these two
did gay guys were like I like straight
guys the problem with gay guys like I
having sex with like other gay men is
that first of all like there they tend
to be way too feminine for me and
so they manicure like to the nth degree
and I was very and big and also it's a
game with thrown [ __ ] yeah there you go
chill we got speaking of dating in top
bottom chin after gay talk right after
Kato we're just gonna transition this we
going in we're going to date machan
we're talking about we're talking minor
seventh called dating chin chin chin
chin how'd it go where were we at with
this and do you need mine and Brian's
health I do need help I don't I just
tried even like installing tinder okay I
did that step perfect you're just at the
insulting uh-uh-uh
I'm trying to find a picture so I have
no idea kind of pictured he's Brennan
but agent a hit me up and she's like she
sent me all these different styles of
pictures that you know I can those dig
yes like there there's there's it
depends what vibe you going for but
pictures and after say a lot we have
good we have some good ones from the
Tori and toss up like busy girl creeps
well no we because we'll be able to
single it out crop it and just have your
faith why don't you just have them why
don't you pose on a log naked with just
that hat with just like but like this
like yeah I'm a cat so we do have that
you do have the tinder profile I'm like
at that profile picture stage so all
right let's get the profile going today
for sure we'll pick the picture I'm
gonna fill it out and then we start
swiping why don't you do this have a
picture of you just with one foot on a
log with with with a fistful of dick no
like like you're holding berries but
it's actually a con I got these berries
for you [ __ ] how you like Korean
blueberries yes that's what the meme
should say I got these berries for you
[ __ ] anyone anyone into [ __ ] vlogs
anyone into egg roll now this is it hey
you guys want you guys want this this
baby bird
no because you wanna say baby and talk
about your dick anyone to Korean BBQ but
it's saw and then exact dot [ __ ]
hey get this baby bird out of the nest
and in the air if you know what I mean
hold it soft there's a baby bird right
now but once you get this bad Louis you
can't sleep better than nesting in the
air you should hold it ditch who's in -
[ __ ] crane Eagle dicks Korean Eagle
did you see a creeper no no no babies
are in Korean Eagle play well that's the
thing he's a you know hey who's in the
[ __ ] you ever seen a Corrine Eagle me
neither
dot-dot-dot suck it Eagles have beaks
and I don't know if beaky I don't think
his dick has a beak bro you wanna know I
don't I do know that his dealer I can
make an educated guess it's boring how
about this hey who digs Korean vultures
all that cuz vultures like to have the
skin of a dick I had I know but can we
just say it's like just Sabo you want
you want yourself you want yourself a
Korean boa
I met that oh it's better than vulture
boa vultures too much porn just say horn
how about some green I love some soul
horn so hard how about some I think it's
too hard yeah okay so - maybe not
grabbing a fist full of dick maybe but
let's get goods going talk here now chin
is it is it frowned upon if I blast your
tinder profile out on my Instagram so we
just get so much traffic me and Brian
guys do and you have your pick of the
milk and I hope listen that we looking
for wifey mm-hmm but we're not some fun
with this guy get some dick like CDs in
there yeah certified dick divers we've
got to have some surf ID like you're in
a slump buster you don't go from slump
Buster Hall of Fame so we're gonna go
slump buster single double gotta get to
them tranches kitchen get your hands
dirty to get you in the trenches a
little bit get you that come and then by
the way don't be all don't be all picky
okay you don't be picky just find the
good there's always something to find
find the good and praise it you
understand I finally good she got a face
like an elephant trunk over no swiping
swipe left - exactly right if they have
a face like an elephant we going I've
had some good times with without and
with an old elephant talk about hardcore
I know that girls who have crazy bodies
and they got they got a kind of face
they got a I mean I'm talking about they
look like a
No I'm down I don't care I'm like well
you know what who find the best of them
won't we just go ahead and turn these
lights down have you ever done that ever
been like this is not a this is we don't
we can't have a well-lit room in here
right now it's it's a million o'clock um
Hornets [ __ ] I'm dirt bag and you're
gonna drop but I just can't keep all the
lights on because if I if I look too
closely the angles gonna throw me off
you know I mean just get let's just go
with a silhouette
yes silhouette issues my imagination but
with you chin and also don't be
promising these girls no boo and [ __ ]
let's not start off the red carpet yeah
actually that's a good point like but
dating doing a cool thing on a date like
like even like one time I asked a girl
if she wanted to go hiking she thought
it was really cool really yeah that's
pretty common this day and age it's very
common but what's a good talent went on
a hike in a silent movie
listen it's 2 on 17 gin there's a bunch
of [ __ ] you can do by I'm funny
there's so much [ __ ] you can do to
silent movie ah
that's finally moving a dick suck but
but but but there is it what we're gonna
do like that's kind of like that people
wouldn't you guys drunk on the first
date 3 what would you drink like you
know why not depends on the chick I'll
get a little rowdy I don't really drink
yeah that's all in Dublin but I don't
really drink but if they need to drink
feel comfortable or listen I'm a Chatty
Cathy I'll talk I can get make friends
with anyone I really don't neither do
you we don't need alcohol but if you
need to like loosen up make her feel
comfortable I'll have a sip red wine
little red wine it'll loosen up get it
get them warm see Emile Emile is a
seduction a meal when you have a meal
with a woman you choose the wine and you
have something to say about wine or you
have something to say about the food or
how is prepared or you just just like
about life yes some say about life
exactly and you know what I think
that's a good way and I think a lot is
lost on a lot of guys I swear to God is
when you talk to somebody and like a
woman like instead of like putting on a
character if you actually talk about
something you're thinking about like an
idea yeah like your philosophy on life
or what you're after in life think of it
like a podcast you like we don't come on
here and it's not scripted and robot and
it's a conversation right that's how
your date should be if you're in the
[ __ ] North Korea right now
talk about North Korea whoo yeah women
are psychological they always say that
the way to connect with a woman some as
women are fascinated with psychology
they're fascinated with the way the
human mind works partially because
that's how they arm themselves against
you know danger they've got to know how
you're thinking they got to know and
they're fascinated with why you feel
that way and they like details but terms
of fascinating down yeah yes you have a
lot of stuffed off you see you're an
artist 40 you know you forty you've seen
the world for God's sake ya know so then
you are you know not to blow smoke up
your ass but you are you're very smart
guy you're obviously very disciplinarian
but you are and so at least some of the
terms we throw around out on the first
yeah probably yeah dick diver in south
dick diver don't call her dick diver
don't say good douche while she drinks
her coffee or whatever don't be like I
can't wait to go douche but she's but I
do think women tend to be into sort of
like how your mind is working well
you're thinking about although if you
watch game your world I disagree I'm
since watching Game of Thrones it
changes me a little bit a little more
aggressive now it's kind of like oh yeah
yeah well they like a caveman at the
same time but they want to get
comfortable with you first before you
you caveman up women like aggression but
it has to be contextualized there's got
to be with a man that she's attracted to
that you have a safe otherwise it's a
salt them yeah yeah the lies you're a
psycho that's right I ask you guys
something
please let's all hear girls what did you
guys do for your actual first actual
date and did you guys know each other
beforehand are you guys kind of like I
took my wife out to dinner in New York
City and then I tried to get her of
course home of course I tried to have
sex with her guests to model yeah very
hot so I was look she had this white
sweater with this
she had the crazy eye I'm tired of dick
was raged I've been alive for 50 years
I'm just gonna say this on the podcast
I've been with a lot of women I put up
some [ __ ] numbers okay my wife over
thumbs naked when she when I met my wife
I have to this day never seen a body
like that I've never seen I'm sorry
his mother of my children I've never
seen tits like that am i [ __ ] I was
like you're like a fairy tale
I'm sorry breasts but it was crazy so I
was like I was having dinner when I was
like all I want to do is I gotta impress
this girl lie to her enough
she thinks I'm cool now I'm gonna get
her home and she took me she knew that
she was like I'm not [ __ ] this guy
and she took me to a club a club because
she knew I hated clubs could I mention I
hated clothes because she knew that
would get me out she was younger - yeah
so I and she would get rid of me by
taking me to some [ __ ] club which I
hated and I would leave uh first date
this standard Callan story so I asked
Joe to go because she was living in
Hacienda Heights kind of far from man
I'm like let me just take out a date
she's working for the UFC at the time
she's like you know you know I'll lose
my job they finally I remember this I
think no one's gonna find out so I was
just kind of new to California I'm like
wish I figure yes bro take her to Joe's
off a bit Kenny it's amazing I'm like oh
hell yeah I'm like 20 reservations now I
should be good on him whatever Thursday
night Friday night I pull my pole I
picture she meets me up place right open
my car door like a gentleman sit her
down drive to Abbot Kinney we pull up to
it I'm telling how great this restaurant
is I'm just regurgitating when town told
me about it like I've been there before
we pull up and it's close and I went I
played on it
that's a Joe's nuts this one and there's
some random yeah somewhat random one
next to it but then something happen
like at the time at a BMW m6 and she had
this expensive like Louboutin person all
her stuff I'm like you let me bring that
inside just leave it here I did
something on my car right like don't
click the button so this is off habit
Kenny late at night it rolled all the
windows down locked the car so she comes
back to us oh my god I'm like wat in her
purse is sitting there said what if
someone stole my purse and oh my god
also try seeing with on the first night
didn't hog that was the reason I liked
your girl dinner I've never forgot it I
never got she comes in joke Demming you
know Brendan had dated girls you know a
lot of different girls we've met and he
brings her to my my brother-in-law and
my sister's house and my wife said I
liked that girl and I said why she goes
look at how she looks at the children
look at how present she is and then she
was said she's classy like she was the
first girl I was like that's a classy
passes for Morris it's on a different
level
shuts this I have to bring it up to her
every time I see her I go Oh seriously
we're at Mott we're at Maggiano's
yesterday and there's a black guy
sitting behind us you know they're loud
and they just came from prices right
cause right next Price is Right studios
and I hear him go that ass is fake I
guarantee that ass is fake and Joe got
ill the bathroom it I went it that's
reacts where the guys threw us you what
she's white am i no she's not white that
ass is really like damn yeah she's
Italian Mexican
yeah whole different thing for you to
know you know set I think it's up to 70%
of relationships start online now like
there's this weird kind of connotation
that it's frowned upon like you don't
know people don't talk about it 70% of
the people you know met online
there's nothing wrong with it like that
the game has changed to meet someone on
the street great your chance is so much
higher to meet someone online so much
honking fat now when I say online it
could be JDate Korean date FarmersOnly
which is white people only black people
only
tinder grinder bumblebee buzz or GTECH
can i dick diverse calm orgy calm your
whole mind yeah yeah there's all that
all right now but also but also
Instagram and Twitter it's no different
than grinder or [ __ ] tinder I don't
know I keep saying Grindr no it's game
but there's no there's no Turing
Instagram and Twitter then tinder yeah
it's people again look at your profile
they dig chin they say a direct message
how is that any different than tinder
I'd have never been on tinder there's
some fake profiles hate tell you ladies
that ain't me yeah that ain't me there's
I'm not on tinder I'm not in bumble but
there was a guy using my my profile my
face for Grindr in Florida I heard let's
see I hope that whoever this have been a
few guys using me for tinder I hope
they're just kidding your picture yeah
and the girl shows I'm saying I'll
[ __ ] I guess I guess the guy must be
decent I guess hopefully that's kind of
like that's a he better be six for 250
that's it you know I mean it's like a
discrepancy know and just feel some
emails all the time like girls like I
thought I was talking in this guy
and I thought it was you mo bomb like
well how'd it come in too bad yeah but
also in there like you need to shut this
down like such an ass I'm not gonna hate
I'm liking the [ __ ] block do ya you know
when I got catfished and then still hung
out with the detail hung out with a dude
yeah so we gonna get this going chin you
know your answer though this is this is
new water for you your yeah I've never
done online dating I always thought it
was kind of odd to see that's BB in 40
I'm sure but now like read up on the
chin you know I'm read up on it's like
that's the thing if you order of the day
a friends that are that are younger
people get married off at all time yeah
do you uh would last last time that a
girlfriend chin geez I don't remember 92
not it was in the 2000s but long long
time ago I moved more than like six
years ago the actual girlfriend yeah
yeah like three years had a girlfriend
then you date her for three years or
years what happened I'm trying to pick
up here ma'am trying to your favor you
know before we get your profile going so
I think we argued a lot near the end of
it and stand we kind of both kind of
wanted what ethnicity was she Vietnamese
it's always what would your argue about
I think just life Baker we would just
get a jealous of different things that
each person would do we'd find reasons
to like here's an important question
that's without social media what are you
looking for in a woman that's a really
important thing to define serious
that's so loaded because why happens
because just up some fat titties in a
math no but I mean we're looking for a
slump percent you're trying to [ __ ]
let go high five percent but wife listen
right now we're an ultramarathon
Chin's gonna have to climb the mud jump
over the bridges you find some ropes my
new console no we're still in it we're
still in the trenches right now we're
trying to get through the trenches got
you we don't have to think that deeply
right now you didn't trying to slay a
dragon your mayor we're not we're not
tactician right now nah man all right
it's like you're smart we know that
we're trying to get the type of mountain
but right now would you know what's Mac
if you do me why front integrate but
that ain't the goal right now if I was
single suddenly and I was on tinder what
would I would I be allowed to want
tinder
I probably signing up for
farmersonly.com I [ __ ] hope you throw
me and some overalls no that's the thing
farmersonly.com is a straight [ __ ]
cover up for white people home they have
commercials with uh with black people
no scene that's just a safe I'm not in
the well I'm not into just white chick
I'm an equal opportunity employer I like
it all so now the question is what do I
do so I would what would my picture be
you'd have to be my stylist stuff I'd be
getting a sweater or my v-neck I'd be
like this I'll put you in a tournament
but every smile budget or like some
kvass seeing them I can't pose for my
tinder picture it has to be something
that I can see that line might
microphone on my hand
nope you can't nope because then they're
like oh I want a day to con with free
tickets you don't want that
[ __ ] your free ticket no you don't want
afraid like that yes you get free
tickets no you don't want that no no
we'll just do a simple head shot I just
kind of my show I feel like I've seen
good ones free chin off all the pictures
we've taken they're taking pictures of
you but you know what I was asking you
guys about you're the ones that you are
with now yeah the the thing you had in
common was she didn't sleep with you on
the first date so that's why when I
here's the podcast now they're gonna be
thinking the same thing my house we
gotta [ __ ] our boy up there yeah cuz
I've had relationships where I have some
where on first day see this ain't Game
of Thrones this ain't Prince Charming
it's okay if you sleep with the guy in
the first night or the guy sleep with a
girl on the first night it doesn't mean
you're a [ __ ] your honor it could be
there's a connection rekt and you're
both attract each other act you just
happen to sleep together around her she
need dick you need a direct there's
nothing wrong without now I have to had
a cat in fact I celebrate that
now maybe two meets his timepiece yeah
and she's great you can't get enough of
chin chin right you're fine kid fan yeah
run accountant Bruns job man and that
night now keep going because I know
where you're going I know I'm going in
the angle now I can play headed hey guys
apparently she wants to meet you too
well you got it when you have a car and
people know cars and you're gonna buy a
car I don't know how it looks shiny whoa
let me look under the hood yeah and the
drives he'd give it a spin let me see is
that what you're talking about
let me let me see what kind of what kind
of space we got that challenge like the
front open the hood up in the world why
come in the back we could booze I put my
sky get hot babes
let me unload my bag take it easy now
let me unload my heavy bag it's
metaphorical in your ass god damn why
can't you keep it a card and you know
what I'm saying yeah we know you're
saying brah let me on wait no see you
always gotta go there you gotta get my
drift
yeah you're in the way before you
brought a sand dick into it I got it
now Chin's on the sunroof point is be a
team player bro because you're on the
sunroof what's he sitting on her chest
this is we're here she can't breathe
look man this is come on I know what
some girls are in I'm just let's just
take with these metaphors here Oh Kenz
on the sunroof oh say she down you're in
the front checking oil right I'm in the
back I'm loading the package you feel
like somebody's gonna slap some of these
balls and I don't feel comfortable we're
all friends here I don't know bro I
don't want it I don't want my balls
hitting your ism you know so happened to
me hashtags happened to me for you
that's hashtag it happened to me with
somebody I didn't even know here's the
thing um here's the thing a caveat to
that I had a caveat to you talking about
it's doing 17 so times are different if
you'd sleep with each other I just feel
like it's different yeah well no she's a
[ __ ] doesn't mean you're you know
here's the caveat here's the caveat
sometimes you make a connection and it's
just overwhelming and it happens now I
would be a liar if I said I didn't say
that to every single girl sometimes I
pretend there's a connection how many
thousand you've been like well you're
obviously obviously I don't do this all
time but there's obviously a very deep
connection you don't feel out of them
then maybe I'm crazy but I don't do this
I'm saying I'm I'm willing to do
whatever it takes to get you naked
because I'm because we add up but we not
have a great time do we not do we not
connect verbally now that closely I mean
I actually might be a hot phone like a
cricket phone it's only the last about
24 hours right now you know I get a dish
that for sure is my buddy in the closet
videotaping obviously and
yeah had it been there through my
phone's crap it's amazing it's amazing
what a man will do to get laid the lies
and the fact you even believe your own
lies because you're like I love you what
you don't even know me I know I never
say this but I want to have children
with you right I just feel like there's
a few thing you can do to not just
separate you from the pack already hey
you have job B you're intelligent dude C
6-4 6-4 3-6 3 let's say we're already
[ __ ] up and then yeah you got a dress
well man a lot of girls will judge you
know what you know what the first thing
you look at shoes yep if you have dirty
shoes they will judge you now if you're
wearing some golden gooses and they're
automatically kind of scuffed cuz that's
the look and they judge you
[ __ ] that [ __ ] she done no shoes yeah
but shoes they look they judge you from
the shoes oh that's why I feel like
funding for my shoe oh you're - in the
shoes okay ask your girl what she thinks
your sh well you're rocking new bow
those shoes are interesting any time I
was Scrooge McDuck Gucci's good you see
the boots I bought for showtimes they
main changes more furious than you being
a pescetarian they're my favorite shoe
of all time
I'm obsessed with how nice non-stop I
lost my [ __ ] I showed them to the Essene
brothers they were like why did they're
so if I could if I was a guy in the back
well you have about the guy the guy in
the back or who's at the Gucci store
friend of mine ah you were to stuff
Friends of the guy who spends a fortune
on Gucci shoes how about the guy in the
back he goes these hadn't come out yet
he was Jared Leto's be the only one -
where am I what'd you just say
it was Jared Leto debuted them on stage
went oh you got my size because yeah I
don't need to see him just give him to
me he brings our best shoes ever seen oh
and Joe goes no I went there the most
ridiculous circuit it's happening
there's circuit is so dope there's rice
but it's like they we just connected no
I'd wear him every day I've been looking
for a boot I can wear every day that's
it oh you can't wear them or I was so
happy
no dude I was so happy you can't warm to
the movies that not one that movies that
not can't we'll have a new drink of a
new alcoholic drink what oh I forget the
name I wrote it down it's super class so
you have a drink now what is it
Campari and soda yes did I call did you
know call her what because I just know
that that's of course what you would
like that's my drink Campari and soda no
she'll do it well yeah but it goes so
well with those [ __ ] boots you how'd
you know I'm friends with my gay a [ __ ]
straight friend Brendan shot what you
see is booth watching [ __ ] rebirthed
now you know that movie behind these a
lot was my baby shoes are there cloth
there's cloth on them
let's plan another there's a flat Idol
if there's a buckle it looks like Jon
Snow is it there's a liner on the front
it looks like great it looks like Jon
Snow designed the shoe Jared laughs yeah
it's got wings they have little wings I
mean I don't even know what to say about
them their shoes make my dick hose
I can't believe enough in the shape of a
huge [ __ ] and by the way of course
Campari and soda and why is that what is
I know you well and I know I'm late for
a drink all my life on it I was at the
movie theater there's nothing I saw old
German order one and he looked really
for sophisticated and very gay no no no
no no timepiece suit movie theater we're
at that fancy movie theater sure this
guy or is one he is nice to element yeah
that's the guy you would he already tell
me what I tried because I didn't want to
bear nothing Joe was drinking I don't
want alright so you took his lead yeah
like you know let me try what he's a man
drink that's nice nice I saw that new
movie Annabelle that scary movie a nabo
that should have scared is it
that's just legit scary David Katzenberg
who is my boy who directs all the
Kohlberg's
he he produced it and he told me that
thing is testing out though I can't
[ __ ] what he said it's testing so I I
cannot wait for it I've never been more
tan about Annabelle was tere Annabelle
was scared and logística you know what's
weird though I'm at that fancy movie
theater no more white dude behind me I
acting like black guy talking
that's the girl don't know I'll know I
thought I was like bro come on man just
ruin it for everyone you said some to
him yeah he kept or I went dude come on
man come on bro anyway alright and then
with chill chill and then the
don't go it god damn it I'm like I kept
just turn around like dude come on man
what's wrong with you nothing more
annoying you have no [ __ ] movie
etiquette it's like the guy who's on his
motorcycle blasting music that lasts or
just so loud it's like you realize when
you do stuff like that that's yelling
you might as well yell out to the world
I have a tiny penis yeah or they have
the big trucks with the monster wheels
on it whoa there on the 405 what are you
gonna do with that yeah what are you do
with that yeah crazy stuff the movie
Annabelle's legit scary though I bet it
looked like it was scary you know me I
love my scary movies I was like there's
some moments I get you it gets you all
your your vagina gets all like not mine
dude I hear you the guy behind I was
drinking a soda and say compart don't
say Kumari maybe super Campari
you you pronounce it correctly come
don't because I know now you're gonna
get a have a saying comparing it's
Campari and soda there's a good chance
I'd miss that
I know Campari and soda I'm gonna drink
it I'm already well it's my drink I have
no strength in my body right but asking
you I drink
oh brother you have a drink go ahead
Brennen what's your drink I've been
doing for years man Campari soda great
boots - thanks man Joe I know you should
be pushing cake in a Jared Leto's mouth
towering over cherry putting one big
[ __ ] strong I don't know man around
its little wings done you guys know me I
love my shoes I've ever been have our
own personal Fight Club and I'm sure
people make for me I don't if you're as
big as you are you can kinda get away
with it it's the only thing I can do you
see my suits this week for Showtime I
just picked them up custom-made wait to
see these hands where they Carl the
coral coral uh once I could a dark teal
until its shape or another one's like
glad ya
the to plan what we can see these you
love color I love so you like I'm not
sure every day if he has women you love
luxury you love I know I appreciate
luxury I like a locksmith ship yes yeah
these suits craftsman she like cars yeah
you love a beautiful car craftsmanship
because we didn't have people who did
that and were into that the world would
be very grey and boring so if everybody
was like me who dressed for utility and
didn't pay attention to that we'd be
driving in boxy cars and we'd be wearing
you know drab clothing and I just don't
think the world would be as colorful
there's this photographer he's a
photographer for Dior and here at Saint
Laurent and he goes we're talking I went
God you got a cool style man here on
this leather jacket this rocked shirt
and these tight-ass jeans and then the
same boots that I have from Saint
Laurent make fun of being black use the
best boots ever had one them every day
once they break in the best now how cool
would you get here he pulls out this
it's almost like a Beetlejuice sports
coat it's like silver stripe with black
and [ __ ] that is sick and he goes you
like oh my god I wish I could pull that
off
yeah he's like really I'm so big yeah
I'd look ridiculous thing yeah those
smaller guys it kills you right yeah
there's certain things I see oh my god
no but you genuinely love fashion well
first time I ever met you yeah well not
but not the first time we ever hung out
you showed up in a in a in a really nice
jacket these cool like Jesus and you had
glasses they were fake but they look
really cool and I was like this
[ __ ] that's the first time I
realized I was like this dude's
different this guy's kind of artistic
yeah I literally like I was like this is
very weird to see a fighter you know I
have this one image of a fighter I
actually know a lot of MMA guys oh my
god I really knew was your Nate
Marquardt but I didn't know any other
guys really it was so distant to me and
then here's this those guys yeah
dude how about yeah I don't know man
yeah and then we kissed
why no I was gonna say we said I'm
excited I leave tomorrow for a Showtime
yeah so tell me what you're doing for
Showtime because this is exciting we're
gonna be there for the fight we know
that yeah so I fly in Tuesday we got
production means all day tomorrow and
then Wednesday we do a show on Wednesday
which is same as like you could see I
did during the tour so that's on
Showtime digital so
so in the show time tours got I don't
know 15 million reasons crazy how big
those things Wow so Wednesday we shoot a
show I'm not sure around what Thursday
same thing Friday same thing day the
fight we still don't know right now it
looks like show times gonna probably go
they're just all boxing analyst team
which I think it's a mistake but it's
it's not my call
they're there yeah cuz they're they're
only gonna go with people who know
boxing who are not know bugs a boxing
match you know so that that's certain I
have one MMA representative
well if there it would be me if they do
I would imagine so it's still up in the
air but I would say more like than not I
won't be on the actual broadcast there's
a small chance but I've great tickets to
the fight in worst case off I'll have
credentials and then for radio row they
want me to do radio road I'm thing about
bringing a chimp but I might I'm not a
I'm a radio guy yeah if you can
guarantee me like two guys that we can
shoot a podcast with yeah I'll bring
chin and other than that and I can do
radio role well the very surprising
thing is that show time wouldn't have a
guy who's an MMA expert and here's why
because you would be able to kind of
talk about Connors tendencies what his
vulnerabilities are as the fight goes on
know what what why why he's keeping his
hand out you'd know that stuff yeah
you know just yeah I again I yeah you
know hopefully bomber yeah but you know
UFC a joint promoter I know they're not
or not they're not they are not if they
were I definitely want to get the job
that's true they probably fill it in
with Dominick Cruz or something like
that
yeah it's an advantage for us that the
UFC is not you know great did I'm sure
dink pull some power move you see Dana
um when you were doing all that stuff
was he around he was around but we
really didn't you know we didn't cross
paths like we got barely see him and you
know he's doing this thing I'm doing - I
have zero ill-will towards him or
anything FC I'm excited for a man you
know what I'm doing it you know it's
good I so you don't know for sure
there's a chance you might that's a
small chance I mean and listen it you
know they always decide late but you
know small chance he'll do something for
show time that night maybe we of course
yeah we don't know either way I I know
worst case I I don't have
answers a fight a front-row tickets the
fight that seen a batch that's historic
but Wednesday Thursday Friday I'm
working for Showtime we know that I'll
be wearing these dope ass suits and you
know wear those boots every night I'll
have no well you got I'm gonna catch you
yes I'm for shoes bro
oh yeah separate back for some to carry
on did I get these maroon Gucci loafers
it'll blow your mind
no mine don't say that don't blow your
mind I make the mad but I you know these
won't make you like these so you got it
off John Gotti okay so there oh they're
there they're legit loafers yeah
maroon leather now now you'll have how
many shoes i mean how shoes you bring
into to the game like wearing six six
pairs experience got some sneaks for
exercise its needs the exercise sneaks
to walk around and its needs to walk
around in and then okay nice like
designer sneaks okay to where you know
you never know dinners I'm sure sorry no
yeah my Gucci's that's good salut I'll
call you know I'm calling the Leto
Gucci's the Leto Gucci got some had a
good gentle Gucci's like that and then I
got this scrooge mcduck Gucci's yeah I
call him the John Gotti maroon loafers a
fellow for some game bears and then I'll
have five different suits with me five
different size of suits for five days
you can't wait to slip into that seared
got it got a pocket square yeah and I
got these like cool like little flower
things and you got a flower thing what
do they call that what do they call that
what do they call those pick all those
what I could add a little flair to your
suit yeah what do they call those things
a flower that you put on if they have
them at wet oh uh brochure brooch no not
approach no let her shoot its course
yeah some of the B rights like French
yeah anyway so you're gonna have you're
gonna be done it up you're gonna have a
plaid plaid plaid everything like a
diamond flowers I call it don't you wear
a fruit basket on your head while you're
at it I mean really good diamond I mean
at the point where I can even watch the
fight we're gonna be like what's what's
with that [ __ ] bouquet of flowers in
the third no I'm thinking about though
like I'm excited for the Showtime stuff
is be so much fun and all that but we
you and I have a show with you know Tom
Segura Chris D'Elia at The Comedy Store
I think on Tuesday
is this seems properly no next who's
next Tuesday next Tuesday yeah I want to
try out some new bits okay so I want to
write though so I'm trying to think how
I'm be able to do I'm thinking when I
get done shooting I'll be able go back
to my room and do so as I'm always
writing though I just don't worry about
that just always be writing like if
you're in the car if you're in the plane
that's it that's not certain stuff I
want to do you know yeah you want to
work it out yeah just in your head
always klutz I do I usually do it in
front of here always be writing but I
want to do some new stuff at the Comedy
Store not no wedington go to the wet
wedding flowers on you know it's it's
what men wear on there for weddings
other things for weddings you mean like
when you go to of course here's a
boutonniere boutonniere a boot 10-year
boutonniere what if I best groom well
let's groom but Boonton is a boutonniere
either way you know what that nope
that's not it that's a pure flower you
need a tiny one that's not it no no
that's not what I'm talking about man
okay damn it I'm not really flower like
goddamn check well bra I don't know man
you know though you got buckles you got
I'm gonna go to Frank gorillas I'll be
fun yeah which brings you a million
opinions there'd be a lot of opinions
there but it's gonna be fun
bro I was at my neighbor had a barbecue
on Saturday I had to record the Terence
Crawford fight because the food came out
late anyways it's me and Terrence
Crawford Jesus Christ but they were talk
about restaurants like they're foodies
and their time Italian food and I was
just like hold up there trauma some new
place on Abbot I guess just crackin yeah
well there's a new place in avid to
Travis from tuina opened that's what
they're talking yeah and it's a ramen
place no no there's an actual no no
there's that place then there's another
yeah Italian I heard there's not a place
it's a small place a small place on
Abbot I get stuff to get into anyways
I'll have to get in there yeah but I was
like no you you know what you [ __ ]
ever been to Via Veneto
first of all they don't know me so I
said [ __ ] yeah and they're all older
right successful men and women yeah
doesn't fly well that's way too
aggressive you didn't help Fabricio out
can help help nope no fact did the
opposite I might've done the opposite
well you [ __ ] I've never heard of vfn
well they kept their
this place down oh no you [ __ ] ever
anivia in a suit I went oh God
normal voice Brendan your normal your
normal voice you know in the podcast
studio I haven't eaten in via vanette oh
wait we neither in a while because
they've been gone they're in st. Barts
running the restaurants there but still
the rest back here now I go I really
gonna [ __ ] juste uh wait a minute you
learned it today we've definitely
children a lot definitely are in it
because we haven't had dinner we haven't
had lunch together and I've been sulky
about sent you a video of you crying
and that's why I've been so I've been a
little salty about that histogram
pockets I know I was I sent that to
Rogan he was dying Jim what are you
doing for the fight going to a friend's
house you you met them actually the eye
doctors that went to the first live show
oh yeah I meant so I met your one friend
from San Diego right she came to the
different friend I met all of them yeah
you bet a lot of Matt the first one yeah
so two of them they're both hi doctors
this fight this fight ends for the first
time around I've had a little skeptical
if it's gonna be the biggest paper you
ever just because the ticket sales I
think they've kind of alienate people a
little bit cuz the price is so high and
then the paper uses a hundred dollars I
still think it's gonna break paper your
numbers you do be in the top how is that
five show selling live I don't think
they know the numbers yet you know are
you saying ticket the gate yeah it's
doing well but I don't think it's deuce
I think their problem is they went Oh
minimum think it's ten thousand dollars
so you know when you have all these IRA
strands come over now [ __ ] that we just
watch it so much so I think it's gonna
pick up this week I think it's new well
I still think it's give me one biggest
pay-per-views of all time
the the thing that made me go is the UFC
goes over the paper you now get this
official may Mac may Mac hat like
they're gonna give merchandise now if
you were the pay-per-view yeah like the
like that is that a sign of all [ __ ] we
need to get moo-ving let's throw some
incentives you know yeah that's
interesting it's interesting it's gonna
be very interesting to see that because
there's always that that I don't know
there's always that danger the people
are glad suspected oh I'm not gonna
watch it the thing is it's it's gotten
the most coverage so if you just go by
off the tour
numbers or anything huge I've done in
Showtime I mean the tour numbers but I'm
the biggest ever ever like talk and
espinosa the head of Showtime he's like
as far as interaction social media
everything said by far the biggest thing
we've ever seen everything and they
compete even when they look at what
happened with Manny Pacquiao and Floyd
it destroys all that so really I'm
basing my knowledge off all that
computing the paper you say yeah well
it's gonna be really interesting to see
I mean everyone's watching it right
that's not why I canceled my Washington
DC game because even though God knows
else was like you sure you want to do
this on this day I was like armed Roden
has to show that night he has a show
that night yeah and he goes I I can't
count the sold-out theater he goes I
went dude if Khan wins you're gonna hear
yeah like you're gonna know it your show
yeah I'm gonna watch on the phone yeah
yeah that's that's that's amazing but
still a broken broken sells out even on
a night like that so you know amazing
yeah gives you an idea of his fan base
yeah well yeah people think you know
Rogen's fan base you know it's just not
obviously not fight fans I had a
conversation with Colin coward on a
plane yeah and he goes yeah program from
fear factor and stuff like what else
does he do I'm like nope well the
biggest comics in the world he goes
really in it yes and but yes yeah you
ain't you only gnome for the UFC
commentator yeah you know like so it
just depends it's a set it's a
subculture and people who listen to
podcast remember a lot of people still
don't listen to podcasts a lot of people
but it's the for the people that do
listen and one thing I that I love about
what Rogan did was that he said I'm
gonna have really interesting leaders of
thought in every field on my podcast you
know he's got social scientists he's got
real scientists he's got physicists he's
got geologists I mean this dude's got
everybody so his podcast as a real
service because it it kind of gets these
really important ideas out of these
people's heads in their books cuz nobody
has time to read them and into our heads
doodle eyes changes our mind the podcast
games grown so it's just growing rapidly
everyone wants do a podcast well I saw
an ad for podcast one in their podcast
with Jericho and I Freight to the other
big ones Adam Carolla like all this
sounds like during a major project like
TV broadcasting Oh like it's only
getting bigger cuz you know people work
I mean I'm so many people to say to
listen this podcast they're doing their
job that we're gonna warehouse or
whatever I dude you're in my TV or my
ear I get to you know I get to at least
laugh and and hang out instead of like
yeah so it's it's it's exciting hey that
video you sent me of the Brian goes
damage this the solar eclipse is crazy
and you go to it and it's a guy it's
like the Sun and you see these pair of
balls go by the Sun I sent it to like I
sent it to my brother Club and I met
since Billy and I sent to my dad I said
to my dad I mean I went okay my dad are
like oh my god really and my dad goes
hey would you sing can't open up I was
like oh just something about the solar
eclipse he was fascinating isn't it and
then I'm just yeah and I was like yeah
pretty crazy man and get a little more
into space these days just trying to
like cover be kidding a little more
interesting is he keep talking about
space I was like oh my god you so fine I
just told my dad am NOT into space
really like I like some of those sci-fi
movies but I sent you a silly video the
guy's balls crops from the Sun no no
response back nothing not nothing
nothing was like oh shut down I got
nothing from my dad I'm getting more
into space these days because I just I
didn't know what to say I got nothing
yeah I was like some curve engine sure
let's do some current events there was
actually one I just saw about the
Eclipse were to tell me so we're blind
yeah so two guys I went blind years ago
oh they're warning people not to uh look
at the Sun three people it was two
minutes that they were looking at and
they're both blinded from it so dude is
article I steer I know you're Trump
staring at it dammit I'm sorry I
literally stared at it for five seconds
in my [ __ ]
not when did it happen would I miss it
today for God's sake what time from like
9:00 to 11:00 maybe 9:00 to 10:30 it's
right here was live I had it up just in
case but I think it's over right
live 32,000 watching it well um check
this out I just saw this right here life
is way too short Alyssa yeah you didn't
know Brian Sam retired no no see today
he's not calling fighting why is that
he's gonna go do real estate and get his
masters read that chin what a great guy
he's life his latest opportunity will
take him away from the role with the FC
and into executive position in the world
of real estate so he's gonna be making a
lot of so he goes I'm announcing my
departure from calling the fights with
the UFC I've been offered amazing
leadership role with a fast-growing real
estate firm and will be attending
Northwestern for my Executive MBA this
fall Stan add that he will still be
attending mixed martial arts events
thanked his coworkers this move is
focused more on my family I traveled 26
weekends last year for work while also
working a full time job to [ __ ]
horrible my new role as a CEO Oh chief
operating officer will be very difficult
but still affording me my weekends with
my wife and three children
transition and change a part of life I'm
really excited to prove my worth to my
new company
hopefully showcase the device diverse
skills military veterans of mixed
martial arts possess for him man
yeah good for him he'll be successful at
anything he does that guy's awesome
yeah I caught me a little off guard I
didn't think he you know he was
definitely good at it what he was doing
yeah I think that UFC had an idea that
he was gonna do that or he just kind of
did it ah no one stand I would assume he
gave him a little bit of a heads up
maybe listen it's professional sports
and they want to give him a heads up if
they're in a firearm so you know it's
all fair and loving I wouldn't upset any
if I would have made sure I had the gig
at this new gig I'm like y'all I'm out
yeah what yeah I got some new gig it's
for sure my wife honey six weekends as
somebody who travels a lot and you
travel now you know what that's humming
how many watches oh how many weekends in
a year fifty-two right yeah that ain't
happening you you you couldn't pay me
enough to be gone that much yeah
how many 52 weeks it's a lot I mean you
know I mean but that that's that's half
half the year this we have three kids
man you miss a lot I miss a ton that's
too much but on your working during the
week and you don't see your that is not
no not worth it man partially blind from
so the clips warn others not to stare at
the Sun not gonna look directly at the
Sun poor guy but also him and his buddy
to 1962 probably no idea 20 seconds they
looked at it looked up at the Sun each
with one eye it doesn't get any worse or
better quotes doesn't get any worse we
both got burned at the same time today
he got the left eye I got the right eye
we didn't know that right the second we
damaged Wow at the time we thought we're
invincible as most teenagers do now I
never thought I was 16 I knew don't
stare shitless of everything man as a
teenager still AM there's that that's it
was so literally my eyes are still a
little [ __ ] up I looked I was like oh
my god they look down some dudes are
grab my kid in rain some dudes are like
you know you've had a lot of friends
like this who are just just reckless
they're just reckless like they do think
they're invincible they're just not but
not enough I was always conscious son
I was always cautious I didn't have a
friend who was like do you know what
let's just stare at the Sun it's a
different thing the solar cluster cuz it
cuz for me I don't have anything else
hurts right away I go
ow nothing do I like that I don't care
if you're trying to be a badass or what
I kind of thing if they forced your eyes
open to stare at the Sun that's a good
[ __ ] that's good torture take sure they
do it get those Isis boys and just make
them stare at the Sun yeah got a refund
do a lot of damage good they didn't go
blind yeah well there's always many
stories about people cutting off eyelids
yes what's work yeah son stare at the
Sun tricked I think did you ever see a
Clockwork Orange
mmm most not heard about it yeah one of
the greatest movies of all time one of
the greatest movies of all time
one of my shocking movies and they show
him they prop his they give him a drug
that makes him I guess
when he sees violence he gets sick you
know they're trying to rehabilitate him
because he loves violence Eve Jack's off
to killing and stuff oh wow yeah it's
it's a it's Malcolm McDowell it's
incredible they prop his eyes open and
they're playing him all these violent
images they please stop make it stop and
they strapped into a chair no and that
was part of his rehabilitation it's an
amazing [ __ ] movie if anybody hasn't
seen it it's it's it's super it's a
masterpiece
it's a master clock research in no
really I don't want to see you now put
on put on just just play for a second a
huge move oh my god
huge it was actually yeah it was
actually a clip the player that if
there's a trailer or anything you know
or a clip whatever it's [ __ ]
fascinating it yeah you got to see a
dude you you just have to it's really
mind-blowing that's a play no I just
wanted to get the oh there you go 1975
yeah Stanley Kubrick is considered a
maybe for many people the greatest
[Music]
I plays Beethoven he loved beta boy this
this preview and give you [ __ ] heart
attack it's it's it's an insane movie
dude I don't let's just preview though
if you want to watch it break another
guy's house
it was kind of like when violence and
gangs were taken over England to code in
imagination people are like you these
thugs grabbing yeah I mean it's a huge
nothing yeah it's probably he said
that's the official trailer
you can't see what it's like but Malcolm
McDowell is [ __ ] I'll check it out
you know play your mind what a sketch in
this a Florida woman she was swimming
where a guy was fishing huh and she got
argument with the guy ended up grabbing
his fishing line with her mouth and swam
off with his lure not an in-floor that's
um what is that sir crying right yeah
Alexandria Turner that's a fisherman on
bid his lord he nibbled at his line and
swam away the bait so she was just a
drunk girl swimming and got an argument
with the fisherman uh-huh that's pretty
much it
Wow cool she's just really really drunk
well well okay what else good let's see
this well he looked at this guy
well Haley says eyes are straight a
convicted rapist found working security
for a rape counseling center yes let's
do some background check but also not to
be a dick but if I see a guy who looks
like that
yeah hardcore one yeah the worst car
ever you're not working in look that
[ __ ] crow you look at his one eye are
you [ __ ] me
that's his situation it's what I call
the evil police and froze like all the
Camellia police in Fresno California say
they discovered that 40 year old Damien
Rogers was working as a guard at
Fresno's rape counseling service center
after he posted a security guard
networking form on Facebook asking for a
sidearm holster for a 45 caliber gun so
that's one thing when you're a convicted
felon he had he got convicted for two
rapes in 98 whole is a convicted felon
he can't own a weapon so he actually
posted on a Facebook like well this is
Jerry Garcia's intelligent mmm well
they're actually helping him out with
the holster but then someone saw his
name did a little check and found out
that he was a convicted rapist I was
back in jail I'd say right now if I'm
doing if I'm conducting job interviews
skrelp him he
nope next why cuz your rapist go ahead
don't need you any a sir no sir it's you
might as well write on your forehead
that I with that note you rape it and
somebody had a deal like guy Jo Queen
even Todd watching yet to do interviews
for our new internet and paid internship
but yeah yeah it has to be yeah yeah so
how did the interviews go let's talk
about this
they're good you did how many three or
four I did like three still be secretive
very nice very nice girls everyone was
good yeah everyone was they all had
their different charms good things about
them professionally personality everyone
yeah all right
we have plenty more to interview yeah so
alright alright here's another teacher
that got so does the fraud and sex with
a fifteen look at those green emerald Oh
beautiful girl my teachers look like
[ __ ] where's the crime hall dish how do
you think she is
40:24 exactly forty whoa he's sexy as
hell to me and by the way hold up the
student was moving from eighth grade in
ninth grade that's just too young of
course of course that's just too young
it's very interesting dude she is a hot
tamale is it's very interesting so much
what's going on the times what I think
it's always been happening just now
social media it's more than yeah I think
it's always been in imagine it's like
Catholics and little boys with hot
teacher what happens to a girl like that
though she's [ __ ] she goes to jail
yeah for a little black two years
[ __ ] dick boy oh boy
how about what's the student look like I
want to know he is dying me y'all never
show this things yeah athlete is he sick
dude that you have a Hoggy on them yeah
cuz then it's like alright the kid was
fishing you know there's almost 50 let's
have the full beer and you know it's
like a fever early 15 yours can be you
know 6 feet 200 pounds dick like a rock
yeah she's probably you know yeah by the
way
16 is 15 you know young its young but my
nephew is 16 that kid old bang whoever
you put in but fun hey 15 those and
my turn he'd [ __ ] he's an ass huh
again I never had people call it an
issue I call it a [ __ ] awesome
passing fantasy I wonder a lot of porno
I'm being yes for me like when it's a
guy a kid and he's got to get it up he's
turned on that's half it when I was
fifteen and there was a woman look like
that I wanted to bang me count me two
out of teacher and that cancer no I know
knows but set of tits if she would have
yeah just made a simple pass like hey
Brandon what do you think of my icing
knows what now look in dim the lights
dim the lights we'll figure it out I'm
the lights and let's look in the other
direction let's go ahead and put some
dogs want you to face the wall and I'm
gonna take care of his no like rotten
soup but let's figure it out well listen
look at her face was the king that's
tough I tell her I probably have done
that even as the creator what else get
chin she's a diamond by the way do you
want to talk about that Terence Crawford
for anymore
hell yeah alright first of all this
isn't Dongo guy so as to is to unify the
belt so no one's unified the belt since
Bernard Hopkins but Antonio
I think Antonio Tarver I'm a bi internat
are would beat Bernard so he was the
last one but Bernard was the first one
to unify the belts when he beat last
year della Hoya
so hasn't been done in forever then so
Terence Crawford in Dongo had the other
belts two belts Crawford has the two
belts they're both undefeated they fight
cry it's in Crawford's backyard in
Nebraska Crawford walks through him
dropped in with a body shot in the
second or third round third round after
yeah so minute 38 in the third round
afternoon down he goes I've never been
hit that hard to ever in my life I've
been Bob Bailey he was never been hit
though she's Crawford the thing is
Crawford to be such a bigger star he
just says zero personality like he had
an interview the next one on ESPN and it
was just hey so what you do is like get
to I got a flat tire and went to an
after-party
oh how do you feel about the win he's
like you know got a good body shot don't
give a something like he just yeah if he
had a bigger personality he'd be such a
big star cuz resume wise there's
argument you could have them pound for
pound number one Oh
I'm what you a was drawn for that 140
this fight was that 140 the time I'm
going up to 147 may be fighting the
winner of Pacquiao horn you know I'd
like to see him fight Mikey Garcia
there's a lot of good fights for him
Thurmond there's a ton of fights for him
he's a freak so he's just as good as the
south ball he's is additional really we
fight in the South ball so you know he
did switch top went south ball the whole
time so you don't know what he's gonna
come out of Wow just as good as one so
let me see bring him up that's crazy man
what an athlete Crawford is that him
right there yeah that's crazy from
Nebraska
freak freak amazing free funny a
spinners great fight meaning he just
walked on but hmm what else your chin
did you know that
Antonio Bigfoot Silva you know he's not
doing well an MMA right now right he's
in like overseas and I think Russia you
cannot doubt Lynott guy still he signed
a fight with Rico Verhoeven
the glory in Christ I'm assuming
Bigfoot's just hoping he and take him
down talking about a guy who needs to
stop fighting Jesus Christ man
he's gonna kill bring up his record just
what this is [ __ ] this should be for a
kickboxing match which makes it rebuild
up it's not MMA no glory kickboxing is
he broke or something I don't know but
this is the worst thing you possibly do
oh my god it's not MMA champ yeah I
thought he was gonna fight that is that
Rico Verhoeven right there he is a
killer
I think I saw him at Bellator I'm just
scary scary dude
holy balls why would Bigfoot do that his
striking is awful and he's slow as [ __ ]
I thought you're just gonna take him
down that's a shame man I don't know why
he's still fighting yeah it's a bummer
sucked yeah similar to the Mayweather
McGregor so it has to be kickboxing for
sure foot Silvan glory recover home
fight it's similar Mayweather McGregor
ah not definitely not sir go to go to
his record for me chin
it's nothing like it matter of fact so
his last so what so really let's go 1 2
3 4 5 6 8 9 10 years he's 1 1 I was less
10 he's been knocked out
Oh hard his last 1 2 3 4 5 so bad for
your head so I just don't get why he's
doing it
who knows maybe needs money man it's a
[ __ ] bummer the nicest guy ever I'm
sure that nicest guy I've trade with a
nicest guy ever
it's a [ __ ] bummer man when you were
trained as younger was he a monster
though he was a monster well he's still
my he's always been a monster birthing
Goff TRT he actually has giantism like
is a thyroid problem he needs trt yeah
there's a he was a tough customer for a
long time poor guy let's get you um how
about this Oh ginger Santa's popped yeah
you know that his fight with friends he
knows off yeah that's positive does he
say for what this is straight they they
gave a substance out but he said there's
no way that he ever took it or knowingly
took it I like to give these guys been
for the doubt because with you sada now
they're so strict guys pop for anything
so before I used to be like oh come on
y'all shine steroids now gotta give JDS
the benefit of the doubt he's gotten
even you know during the you know I I
don't know I give that for them you can
pop for anything with these things I
guess you say there's diuretic yeah was
it was a diuretic that's known to like
you know help you pass tests whatever a
seal the conceal actual drugs well that
could be an issue France you know wants
over it yeah that's here you know what's
hearing a peep the try and keep frets on
the card but mmm that's a bummer
it's obviously JDS on the back I would
say my nose korat say back to of square
you get flagged for this
the thing is suspended tough - gotcha
yeah unless you want to see this I'm
sure you guys don't like this floor
County Bands homework aspirants have
read with their kids instead well these
kids have such busy days I can
understand what they're so you do see
their point yeah yeah they're seen it
doesn't really help don't need homework
homework you don't learn too much it's
just about getting a task done yeah I
don't want kids stress out about a
homework they they get stressed and it's
really hard on them out of work yeah
like that extracurricular activities
when you got sports and everything else
then you got to come home and do
homework you have no time with your kids
I don't like it I'm like what's she
doing homework for I want to do homework
dinner's been yeah some of these kids
like my nanny's kid come over there
homework it is like what the [ __ ] a
lot what gradient she was anything oh my
god I think you're in college right if I
teased the kids they're not learning the
contest what they're doing is learning
how to pass the test or how to finish
the homework correct and I procrastinate
I never did homework I waited to the
last second I and the Internet you're
not you're just looking up answers
anyways it's not the way you used to the
world's changed man yet the remaining
keep there keep trying to these alters
learn from those old books till they're
not adapting it's tough man it's true
what else you got you is that it I think
so there's nothing really too amazing
alrighty alrighty I'll do a quick remote
now I won't be able to do well probably
won't be able to do your tinder profile
tomorrow probably next we couldn't get
back we'll launch that well fine taking
it on the chin take a picture and
everything tinder match in yeah you know
everyone wants overwhelmingly tinder I
see every gender I like genders and
that's kind of a given I have a question
with all gender gender is really funny
let's call it gender actually Chindi is
perfect chin is good that's the standard
tinder Chindi now for our gender segment
and now for chinder that's great and
then chill how'd your date go no one
after we got pictures jogger yeah I want
to just give a quick shout-out to our to
our boy Matt who basically did that dick
diver awesome dick diver thing called um
you know I had that t-shirt I sent you
yeah very funny
quick quick shoutout but you know yeah I
get so much artwork about you've a shot
I'd be too outside you seem so quiet
snow that's a great one for sure but his
name is Matt all right Liz Matt and he's
on your I'm telling you reposted it you
can you edit this out I know no but his
name is so well done burn Matt's but no
what do I say not Matt ray certified
dick diver t-shirt I sent you that it
was hilarious great guy and his name is
ray poo Naida rape Renetta from Olympia
Washington you're a man happy birthday
bro that's great way to go ray ray now
he's really talented
okay here's my drop of knowledge ready
here's my here's my driving knowledge do
you ever wonder why I have a question
why do you think people in Boston have a
different accent
for example then say somebody in New
York which is pretty close together why
do people in New York have a different
accent people in Philly like why the
accents change regionally or even in
London why do people in London itself
they're 15 different soloists are
talking about weighing that we pick up
on the tenth ease right it's that
culture it's the sub time so so but but
but so in other words what happens is
this is a prominent theory anyway
is that when you somebody older you
admire when somebody's older and you
admire them you will copy the way they
speak and so the leaders in your
community speak a certain way and then
you speak that way and then you copy
that person you copy that person and
that's kind of how human beings are we
always look up to somebody we need
example we would start off as kids
correct all right you start off as kids
starts off I don't know if that's true
but just hear me out yeah so Tony and
his wife are from Sunderland England
they have thick accent yeah their kids
they don't you know their since the
babies they're around those accents they
don't have access okay but that's also
because they're and they're around other
people in a different country so they're
a couple things that influence it one is
the language you came from the culture
you came from so you may have a second
language you may have a different
culture
that actually informed so if you're
Irish and you come to Boston over
generations your accents going to be
it's still going to be informed and
influenced by your heritage but but for
example with that as an example is the
reason kids will take on not the accent
their parents but they're in school or
they're around social they're
socializing with kids who come from this
particular region and so they admire
their peers and they admire people that
are older but it's interesting because
that's kind of how human beings get
smarter we are able to download software
we're able to download cultural software
what makes human being so so special is
that we are really good at learning not
only from each other but also discarding
the stuff that we don't need and so
that's one of the reasons they think is
like you know you just copy the people
you look up to different kinds of power
you know the power that's called
prestige where you look up somebody you
look up to them and you can't take your
eyes off them and you want to emulate
them then there's other power which is
are you going to do what I say I'm gonna
punch you in the face that power doesn't
usually actually last you know what they
say about that like societies that have
great power like you know they're run by
dudes with the biggest mouths dictate
what happens did you create a whole
bedrock of resentment underneath you and
they're plotting your demise and so it
was in cypher I can't remember leave cut
do you hear about with artificial
intelligence your fate so Facebook I was
reading started on you know Facebook I
know did are there artificial telogen
s-- and so it started off with you know
artificial antennas and they were
communicating they went hold up how are
we speaking English these [ __ ] in here
they started they made up their own
language and face we kept pull the plug
dude I think that's that's terrifying
Facebook little click that's terrifying
they were going back forth so everyone
humans could follow it and then the two
artificial sediment hold up I would want
to all these people understand what
we're [ __ ] down now
and they came up with their own
kineticast I never heard that but that's
terrified people in Facebook Mike
Zuckerberg but this you know and he was
like no you should not fear AI and they
pulled it immediately because the other
thing they haven't they're they're
having a problem with is it so when you
go on Facebook and you look up say Flat
Earth
example the problem is that there's an
algorithm they have no control of
because if Facebook starts to see you
doing like you're interested in Flat
Earth you're gonna get more of those
okay more for sure that is that is not
now I happen it's also flat that's you
you can like start getting the algorithm
will start pushing you toward more and
more evidence that there is a flat but
that's the way that's the way almost
internet works in general so if I went
online I went vacations to Mexico right
that algorithm downloads so I mean they
can't control I go to shear dog and then
boom it pops up Mexico trips or if I'm
looking at shoes you'll see these shoes
pop up in your face sounds well you care
about that yeah I rob how about that I I
know my in Mark Zuckerberg was one like
Shane oh no where'd you read about it
worked I'll send you the thing Mayer
Tesla was I glistening on a eyes nothing
to [ __ ] with I'm telling you it's
trouble and Zuckerberg was like now we
shouldn't fear it's all good
check it out they did thing and the
artificial tender like [ __ ] these humans
come with our only it's right literally
within like barely doing it they're like
[ __ ] humans own language they're like
what is Bill Gates Bill Gates Yount a
Tesla the guy test they they were all
talking about this there's there's a
computer scientist who wrote a book that
I had on my podcast back in the day and
you know and I had him on the clock
that's because Bill Gates and Moss and
Elon Musk they were all like they're all
you gotta listen to this [ __ ] guy and
he was saying did you know artificial
intelligence it can cause it can even do
weird things he was saying look it's not
like it's gonna create robots that are
gonna kill us because it has no respect
for its biological heritage yes that's a
possible lay that letter down lines will
apply but there are certain algorithms
that could cause like a company or like
are a bunch of commuters to start making
you know ten billion paper clips that
you don't need they'll just start
spitting out paper clips and and you
can't shut it off so now you've got just
all these paper clips like there's all
kinds of implications that can cause
major problems just create a whole yeah
well you know using like insane amounts
of iron that we need for other stuff to
make paper clips all of a sudden and you
do it was just a mistake you know it was
pretty you know talk about blasting on
last morning
I was just you on must tweeting about
what he actually went met up with
Zuckerberg yeah and then told him like
yeah you know what his understanding of
the subject was limited he didn't know
what
Elon knows yeah we going listening on
mas I will a little bit I love Mark
Zuckerberg I knew has done is brilliant
but I think is a little bit more and
probably involved in the actual you know
my only things I think musk is a you
know when guys are this smart they are
tad crazy like he's like I don't want to
be on earth in ten years I will relax
relax
well readable yeah a little bit but read
a book by Ray Kurzweil people ask me
what could to read all time the
singularity is near the idea that that
you know computers are going to start
mimicking human brains and going way
beyond it's a really good book and Ray
Kurzweil has more patents than I think
any American living there you know one
of them one of the most hey dude where's
the article can you find that article
tune where you users type in Facebook a
I test goes wrong or something like that
there it is Facebook in there's panic
Pope laughter BOTS develop their own
language dude this is gonna be the
biggest the AI bots were originally
programmed to use plain English to
communicate with one with one another
were found to be speaking what appeared
to be gibberish senses like I can't can
I everything else and balls have zero to
me to me me me me me me we're being set
back and forth by the AI while humans
have absolutely no idea what it means
the bots fully understood what they were
saying freak you without being able to
understand how or why the box for
communicating Facebook had no choice but
to shut down the system scares me scares
me hilarious alright random where you
gonna be
what were you gonna be an excuse damn
The Comedy Store my favorite place ever
Comedy Store with Brian Tom Segura Chris
D'Elia
Sam Tripoli I think there's a few
tickets left that [ __ ] might be sold
out that's the Comedy Store it's always
sold out that's nothing to do with me
and then September 22nd I'm
laughs factor in Long Beach and that is
almost sold out t FAC a.com have more
date for you guys soon Long Beach
September 22nd I'm in Madison Wisconsin
comedy on state I believe that is
September 21 22 23 or maybe it's
something like that oh it's great man
yeah and then I met I know
detailed uh filly at helium comedy club
September 28 29 30 so whatever that is
yes so I think I'm 21 kids album
actually 19 20 21 yeah boom P Phi K that
combo everything I'm seeing me boom boom
boom is that it bud you some comedy
buddy let's go eat some food man let's
do it
this is a fine kid we're out